bailey oberg
making his 10th start of the season 1-1
with a 5-4-5
that's hooked
gordon way on the grass and ohtani blows
right by first base
there goes ohtani swung on and missed
and the one-off throw
got him
jeffers with a one-up strike throwing
out ohtani
and jamie berea his first game of the
angels since the 18th kepler with 10
career lead-off home runs
this one is fair and this one is gone
and today the twins strike first
kepler
got a 3-2 fast while he can handle it
you see catcher max stass reach back
across his body set up outside
now rooker blast won the left and this
one's not coming back
into the third deck
and the twins who didn't over thursday
friday or saturday
get two quick ones here sunday afternoon
[Music]
that was impressive that was a bomb
here's the next delivery and in march go
after that one they say he was holding
on here's stassi now
stassi
right center
cave and kepler cave leaves and he
doesn't have it it bangs off him and the
wall
marsh will score easily and the angels
are on the board and all the way to
third base with a triple is max stassi
slower breaking ball changing speeds
with the breaking ball and he comes back
to strike him out
driven to right and
kepler into a slide makes the catch
do away
nice play by kepler you need to commit
to that catch pretty early on when
you're gonna catch a sinking line drive
two strikes
and a breaking ball gets a good inning
for over
a one two three a quick one two three
third inning
missed down and in and the twins get a
lead on walk
little flare
fletcher spinning throwing
got him
simmons says no
here's our first look
how quickly he spins around to
anticipate he might have a play
he's got it he beat it all right quick
and easy
to short
fletch is there and the inning is over
trying to find a seam in the shift
and good play the safe call is made
mayfield the diving stop
oh walsh is just so good at that
turns out right down the line is our
top tier play presented by arco
jack mayfield again showing the range
and then the stretch and the scoop from
walls at first and that'll bring up max
stassi does nancy have the triple angels
had a run stass rips that one left field
line and it's gone
a laser to left
and this game is tied
well you got the two hard ones out of
the way right away a triple in a home
run
for maximus entertaining us today with
the bats
six hits in the ball game this little
curve off the bat of fletcher going to
be feeling by snow he's going to have to
turn around under it flipped over and
not in time ober saying hey go to the
review because ober got there but he's
looking at the shortstop position
by a whisker i believe the twins
will get this call over turn
foot descending i don't know
and they did get the call overturned
okay
danny coulomb coming in to pitch to
ohtani and then upton with one down on
the sixth so he gets ready to face the
angels and he'll be facing shohei ohtani
here's the 1-0
oh toddy
right field the laser and it's gone
35
sunny days
shohei
showtime
in minneapolis 35th home run that ball
is crushed what a swing by shohei ohtani
now 61 extra base hits giving halos the
lead now
swinging 3-0
not at that one
second time that maria's given up the
lead off walk
mayfield
fletcher
double play
and clutch again for berea getting a
double play and getting that baseball
hit to that man the captain jack in
third
according to left
and upton's there and he makes the catch
hits it hard
fletcher is out there i mean way out
there
and just gets the speedy polanco
right center
marshes there
how about jaime barria
seven innings in the books
first batter up for the angels starting
things off here in the
top of the eighth inning and bunning a
ball out of the reach of the first
baseman sano is the lead off man in the
inning adam eaton and he will get a one
single so that's how the angels
eighth inning begins
alexander coleman will come in for the
38th time
there's the bunt
call him bare hands fires a rocket to
sono a sacrificed bunch by mayfield
and eaton gains second base
which vacated third base sono with a
nice pickup looks across the diamond
makes the smart play there that ball
smashed by fletcher and the fans are
booing because ohtani is going to be
intentionally walked our own fans of
going because of that i want to see the
man play
tapper to third hasta deal
a target to sono
full of a strands two it's still a
one-run game
after seven splendid innings from jaime
barilla steve seashek in the
eighth
and donaldson takes his second walk and
there's a man aboard now personal and
this is why taylor rogers is warming up
even though the twins
are down a run if so no cranks one here
rogers will be ready to come in for the
ninth inning
ah the frisbee
the slider and a sharp one and seashek
gets through the eighth
marshes over two walked and scored
in the second
runner goes 02 pitch and into
right-center field that's a hit
marsh finds the gap iglesias racing
around third headed home thrown to the
plate he's in there an insurance run a
big one for the angels
stassi that's into right field
marsh to third to the plate he is in
there
five two angels two outs in the inning
with a runner on and jack mayfield will
be the next batter
went down and got that drives it in the
gap and another runs coming across
jack mayfield
putting an exclamation point on what has
been an outstanding four-game series
here in minnesota tony watson
will relieve steve seashek who was super
in the eighth
to left and it's caught ball game
lagaris out there runs it down
and the angels have won the series they
take three of four from the twins back
to 500.